where are you going to be able to make
money by investing in ways to reduce
emissions we already know that
wind and solar installers are like among
the biggest fastest growing jobs in the
country
yeah making the economic argument always
gets everyone's attention
well wade thank you so much for joining
us and making us smarter on this really
appreciate it
now staying with all things green we
want to invite you to join our virtual
bloomberg green
summit which begins on monday it's our
annual event for the new climate era on
monday you'll
get to hear from former vice president
al gore as well as ariel investments
co-ceo and president
melody hopson be sure to register for
the event at bloomberglive.com
now separately president biden is
looking ahead to his next phase of
reshaping the u.s economy
and to get there he plans to double the
capital gains tax rate for the rich to
almost 40 percent
that's according to people familiar with
the proposal coupled with an
existing surtax on investment income
that means
federal tax rates for millionaire
investors could be as high as 43.4
percent
this proposal could reverse a
long-standing part of the tax code that
has middle-class workers paying
a higher tax rate on their income than
wealthy individuals pay on their
investment income
maddie coming up celebrations sadness
and calls for more
action black lives matter co-founder
opal tometti shares her reflections on
the outcome of the derrick chauvin trial
in the state of policing in america stay
with us we're back in two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
while many call the conviction a former
minneapolis police officer
officer derek shovin justice activists
say the fight is far from over
and there's more work to be done earlier
i spoke with black lives matter
co-founder opal tometti about
what it was like to navigate this trial
and why now is the moment to keep moving
forward in addressing racial injustice
we heard about the verdict convicting
derek shobin in a murder that we know
that he did and so it was almost like
you know reading the weather we knew
that he did it and so having him
held accountable for his actions was
incredibly important for the
millions of people who rose up and took
to the streets around the world
so i think this for for many of us was
just like a
a real sigh of relief um a real sense of
vindication
something that we knew needed to happen
it was absolutely necessary
and yet the fact that we were sitting on
pins and needles
for you know weeks on end wondering
whether or not this man
would be found guilty was um is also
deeply disturbing it speaks to some of
the
challenges in our society and challenges
this policing overall
so you know i'd say first you know i'm
glad i'm glad he was found guilty that
was the right thing on all charges
and then secondly i would be remiss if i
didn't mention that there are
many other people who have been killed
but at the hands of police
during that trial and so we know that
the challenges
are profound they're systemic um it's
not just a one and done this is not a
transformative moment this is one
um uh incident where we are finally
seeing
accountability um yet true justice
would require the system change of
course the day of the derek chovin
verdict
we heard about micaiah bryant who was
fatally shot by police officers in
columbus
ohio today is dante wright's funeral the
list of names
unending what does that rapid succession
of names mean to you
about policing in america
sadly it's a testament to the fact that
our work
is far from over you know we started
black lives matter
over 70 years ago now and clearly
the work yes has gained momentum yes
more visibility yes
you know more notoriety and public
praise and acclaim and
nobel prize nomination and all those
sorts of things
yet the fact is if black people can
still be
you know gunned down in the street they
can still uh be killed with impunity
we still have a real systemic challenge
on our hands and we're going to need
real
uh transformative policy changes in
order to address that
and to me seeing those names and hearing
the stories
just this past week week and a half two
weeks
has broken my heart and we can't seem to
even really rest and celebrate the the
verdict
before getting another story of a young
black girl
being killed at the hands of police
what kind of work do you think needs to
be done to really
put a stop to the police brutality that
we've seen again time and time again in
this country
black communities deserve to be invested
in we need
job opportunities we need health
services
we need mental health uh first
responders
we need other types of solutions that
look at black
people with the respect and the dignity
that they deserve
we're of course hearing calls to abolish
or defund the police with many saying
after the verdict that abolition was the
mission
where do you sit with that my hope
is that we continue to ask the tough
questions to be grown-ups
and to do the work of transforming our
society where we can have
a multi-racial democracy that works for
all of us
and so it's step by step and i and i
hope that we will see a world
in which we we don't need police anymore
right where we see and we are defining
safety
in a more broad and comprehensive way
where we're looking at solutions to
challenges on our community
um in a more dignified manner and i
think we can do that
but i do think that's going to take you
know that's gonna take commitment that's
gonna take experimentation
and just like we've invested you know
billions of dollars in one arena i say
like why don't we
take those resources and begin to
experiment with other solutions
that might be out there that we haven't
tested we haven't
um given them the opportunity to try out
in all of these years
clearly this isn't working clearly we've
seen
we've seen what is going on we see the
status quo
and you know it's enough it's time to
try something new
can't thank you enough for joining us we
we so appreciate it thank you so so much
thank you
thank you
we'll have more of our conversation with
opal on at quick take on social media if
you want to watch more in scarlett one
thing that she also mentioned earlier
that i found to be so profound was just
this feeling of exhaustion
this verdict coming out she hasn't
stopped working since you know she
hasn't slept
and uh just got the sense from her that
she feels like there's so much left
to continue to do yeah it was a relief
in so many ways just it marked an
a turning point but also as you
mentioned a signal that there's a new
chapter to forge
on this all right we want to turn our
attention now in the meantime to the
pandemic
and we'll start with india whose numbers
on coven 19 deaths are currently at odds
with the bodies piling up at
crematoriums and burial grounds
so that leaves a data gap that could
keep india unprepared to fight renewed
outbreaks
india reported almost 315 000 new cases
today the world's highest ever daily
tally
by comparison the u.s saw a peak of just
over 314 thousand cases
back on december 21st and the new surge
in cobit infections is threatening to
further divide the global economy
between the rich
and the poor and it could damage overall
global growth if the fresh outbreak
spread
or if key sources of demand falter
more people were diagnosed no i can't
get my words out today were diagnosed
with covid last week than
any other time since the pandemic began
to get a better sense of where in the
world covet is spreading and to track
the global inoculation effort
visit bloomberg dot com forward slash
coronavirus a wealth of information
there
maddie coming up after the break the
road to innovation
may help improve your travel time and
climate change
we'll explain when we get back into
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
replacing gas guzzling cars with greener
vehicles is certainly one way to reduce
our carbon footprint
but the future of transportation is
still very much a work in progress
and one possible step forward is
hyperloop it's a new technology that
promises to be time efficient
and cleaner for the environment it's in
development by a number of companies
including virgin hyperloop whose ceo and
co-founder josh geigel
joins us now josh good to see you on
quick take thank you for joining us
to start us off for those who aren't
familiar with it briefly explain what
hyperloop is we know that elon musk is
very excited about it
or at least he was a couple years ago
but tell us how it works and what kind
of carbon footprint it leaves
we're still very excited about here but
hyperloop's a new form of transportation
it's taking you directly to your
destination without stopping at any
place along the way
and doing that in a i'll say at the
speed of an aircraft
without all the emissions that are
associated with flight
and so we're able to do that by having a
onboard propulsed vehicle
we're able to do that with having
batteries on board and then when you
show up to a station or show up to a
portal
you go when you want to go you're not
waiting you know hours for a train or a
plane to go
and the real i think exciting point of
this for us
is this idea of sustainability without
sacrifice
so the point that we can basically go
the speed of an aircraft
not have to wait but also do that for a
fraction of the emissions about 10 times
less energy than an aircraft
okay so it sounds amazing and these
simulations are incredible i mean any
transportation fan and anyone who cares
about the environment would just be
uh taken by it last november virgin
hyperloop ran its first crude ride
in the desert outside of las vegas i
believe you were on there
it's still though very much a concept
where is the us government
in terms of actually writing rules for
it and investing in it
i think this is the opportunity that we
see with the pandemic we're seeing you
know the biden administration put out an
infrastructure plan
and this idea build back better we want
to create the future based on technology
that will help us solve
problems we can't continue to use
technology from last century to solve
the problems that we have today climate
change and the like i mean i don't use a
computer from 1980
so i shouldn't use a transportation
system from 1960 or even 1920.
and so if we're going to buy some or
build something new build something
better when you look at
creating new infrastructure for people
we want them to have a better experience
than
they have now which is going to be an
aircraft and then doing that in a way
that's responsible
for us and then for our future
generations okay i understand all of
that but a lot of work needs to be done
the really boring bureaucratic work that
governments need to undertake and if
anything my understanding is that
it's farther along in places like europe
which has already started setting
standards and regulations
walk us through the steps needed to make
hyperloop commercially viable
in europe so to make it viable what we
have to go is actually develop the
technology as you saw we did a test i
was in that with my colleague sarah
and we were the first passenger test and
we have to take that two passenger
vehicle we have to move that to
about a 28 passenger commercial vehicle
we're doing that
in our facilities in los angeles and las
vegas in conjunction with that
you're developing the rule sets with
independent safety assessors the same
way that europe does trains
we've actually done that with the
passenger test that we did before
and continuing to do that as we go
forward so this idea of an independent
third party
that makes it i'll say deemed safe
that's what the regulator is actually
looking for and that's how we intend to
take this to market
both in europe and across the world you
mentioned uh trains in europe does
hyperloop get us closer to high-speed
rail which is something else that a lot
of environmentalists
in the u.s talk about i think it's it's
actually way more than getting us closer
to high-speed rail blows it away
so you're able to go three times as fast
you're able to do that when you want
you're not having to deal with other
vehicles on the track or things crossing
it or whether
you're in an enclosed tube you're going
at the speed of an aircraft and
on an on-demand setting so your vehicle
is going direct to your destination it's
not stopping
at every place along the way so it's not
just recreating rail it's actually
leaving rail behind and moving forward
to what
we should experience for on-demand
transportation in this century
so along with virgin hyperloop there are
a number of different companies working
on the technology on the form of
transportation
i just did a quick check and i've seen
up to 15. what do you say to critics who
make the argument that the technology
will never work but the research that's
being put into it is still very valuable
i think just wait just wait for us to
show you i mean they told us we couldn't
start a company they told us we couldn't
build a system they told us it couldn't
be safe for passengers and we've done
all those
you know i think the the opportunity to
build a brand new system
that's what we're doing right now and
plenty of people said you couldn't land
a rocket
and people didn't build a plane and yet
here we are today with planes and
rockets that land themselves so
i think it's just a matter of time
technology will be able to solve it all
josh quick question for you before we
say goodbye um is elon musk
positive or negative for hyperloop
overall i mean he
obviously has weighed in in the past but
he's not doing anything with it beyond
heading a boring company which you know
drills those tunnels
i can't comment for elin himself but i
do know if he has an idea he usually
sees it through
and i think we're taking up that mantle
of really taking that idea to the next
level and trying to put it out there so
i hope he's hope he's excited about what
the future looks like
ceo of co-founder of virgin hyperloop
thank you so much for joining us really
appreciate your time
maddie sticking with climate change a
global problem
at the local level in this week's city
lab segment we're taking a look at how
big cities are adapting as they're
increasingly threatened by coastal
flooding
quick takes matthew albany spoke with
city labs linda poon to find out more
so linda first off thank you for joining
us i know one of the main things that
you talk about in your store are cities
with an estimated more than half the
world's population living in some sort
of urban environment
how exactly are cities impacting climate
change
right so people in cities are always
moving right they're commuting they're
working they're using
um energy to heat their homes hit their
office or cool their office
summer times coming over here in the u.s
so that means cities are constantly
using energy and they're one of the
major contributors to global greenhouse
gas emissions
um which you know contributes to climate
change
um in which cities are uniquely
vulnerable to its effect so
at the same time though because there
are so many people living in cities and
there's going to be even more people
living over the next few decades
there is this urgency to make cities the
forefront
of curbing climate change um so there
are a lot of efforts out there to
you know cut greenhouse gas emissions to
make cities greener and more efficient
basically to mitigate the impacts of
global warming
right and i i wanted to speak to some of
those points i know you talked about it
as a 15-minute city
in your piece that you talk about um
what are some of the ways that you know
some of these cities are trying to
mitigate
the impacts that they're having yeah so
with the 15-minute city concept
um the whole point is to
sort of reduce car use right traffic is
the second largest contributor to
greenhouse gas emissions
so there is real incentives and what 50
minute city
does is essentially make neighborhoods
self-sufficient so
the idea is that you live 15 minutes by
bike
or by public transportation or even by
foot
to everything you need your job your
hospital
your school and that way if you don't
need a drive then you have
you know less reason to and and in that
way
cities are able to sort of cut carbon
emissions
but other than that cities are also very
focused on
cutting building emissions right
building emissions are actually the
number one
contributor to greenhouse gas in cities
that means making buildings more energy
efficient
heating and cooling takes up a lot of
energy
and in older buildings which you know
some of these cities are historic
um there's a lot of need to renovate
them um and to make them
basically um greener interesting and so
is this something that we're seeing
mainly one country doing in
isolated areas or is this more of a
global effort
in ways to help reduce the impact yeah
so for sure it's a global effort right
you have hundreds of cities that sign
onto the paris agreement
in 2015 with the goal of lowering
or sorry of keeping uh global heating to
below two degrees celsius so there is
this understanding
that you know cities all over the world
have to work together in order to make
some sort of difference and and cities
really are leading the way
you have cities in u.s who are
completely changing the building codes
new york city has one of the most
stringent building codes now
in order to make buildings more
efficient cities in europe
basically paris is spearheading this
15-minute city idea and it's encouraging
a lot of other european cities and u.s
cities to
follow suit in china there they're
trying to electrify public transit
in order to reduce traffic congestion
right and and those
and the carbon emissions that come from
traffic congestion so it's a huge city
effort
you have organizations like cbp um
tracking the
progress and you have coalitions like
c40 that are
you know making sure that leaders are
following through
with the targets that they set obviously
a fight against mother nature is very
difficult the strength before for cities
was that they were able to be along the
coasts
be these hubs these ports are there any
ways that these cities are trying to
you know prevent any of the disastrous
measures that could happen with the
impact of
climate change yeah so if coastal cities
flooding from sea level rise is the
biggest threat
is the threat right and it's sort of
inevitable it's it's a question of how
much we can stop sea level rise right
and in time post flooding is happening
right now
what cities are doing are are trying to
mitigate the effects
so you have some cities use more
traditional methods like flood barriers
and sea walls so
if you look at venice venice is set to
complete a billion
dollar flood barrier project that is
expected to hold back water during high
tide
and it's a very controversial project in
terms of its efficiency
and and the and the price tag um so
so cities are trying different ways and
it's it's a question of
whether these are going to work in the
long term here in the u.s
researchers are already predicting you
have possibly 13 million people moving
away from the coast
because of flooding over the next few
years well i think it's safe to say now
more than ever
the entire world is watching so
bloomberg's linda poon thank you so much
once again for a fantastic reporting and
taking time out of your day to talk to
us
thank you so much for having me
we're going to switch gears now because
coming up after the break a cunning
coming of age story that just makes
sense in 2021 we speak with writer and
director may makino about her new film
in between girl
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
here's what a coming-of-age movie looks
like in 2021 an awkward teenage girl
grappling with racial identity a love
triangle and a broken family
all under the glare of social media it's
a pretty far cry from the teen movies of
the 90s and the early millennium
in between girl which premiered at south
by southwest last month
hits all the notes of a modern coming of
age tale and more
so i want to welcome the film's writer
and director mae makino now
congratulations on winning the audience
award in the visions category at south
by
uh may this was your first feature film
i want to
start by asking how much of it was based
on you because
you definitely share some similarities
with the lead character angie in that
you're both biracial and you're both
artists yeah um so of course quite a bit
um
of angie is based on me you know i think
all the characters kind of come from me
in some weird way um whether that's just
like their insecurities
um or kind of their quirks but i think
angie for sure
um there were like a lot of things i
think
just being biracial and kind of having
to deal with
kind of fitting into two different
cultures and kind of feeling out of
place
and you know growing up i think um it
was hard for me
to kind of feel a part of a lot of
things
um and so that that element was
definitely kind of based on my life
at one point i read that you wrote angie
as half mexican in half black
that was your first draft why did you
decide first of all to go in that
direction
yeah so growing up you know i very much
had angie's experience i was like
the only um person of color
um at a white episcopalian school um and
so i didn't grow up with a lot of like
asian friends unfortunately but i did
have like a lot of black
um and hispanic friends and then i had a
lot of like
black and hispanic students when i
taught filmmaking
and so you know i think i was just like
okay i'll just write a character kind of
based on them
um and i've said this before but i think
it was
you know i it was easier for me to write
about it like kind of wearing kind of a
mask
but then we decided to kind of open
auditions up to
anyone who is non-white and emma
galbraith who plays angie
is half white and half chinese and she
was just amazing
interesting how you pivoted based on the
talent that you attracted i really
appreciate your sharing that story about
wearing a mask what i love about this
movie is that it's extremely female
positive
the popular girl is not really a mean
girl there's
conflict and tension between angie and
the other secondary female
characters but there's also a lot of
relating and learning as well
was this an intentional pushback against
um female characters that you had seen
depicted in teen movies when you were
growing up
oh absolutely i think um you know a lot
of
what i grew up with um was kind of like
teen movies where the goal was to get
the guy at any cost
um and you know a lot of times like
something like
16 candles comes to mind you know
like jake ryan is totally awful to his
blonde girlfriend he kind of just
gives her away when she's drunk um to
the nerd
and watching that was like kind of
really terrible and i wanted to kind of
show
what i had grown up with which was a lot
of times like the women
i had been jealous of were really really
cool
and i ended up being really great
friends with them now you started
writing this script in 2017
it premiered as i mentioned earlier this
year right as reports of anti-asian
violence were picking up
and by the way the senate voted to pass
the hate crimes bill
and it now is going to the house most of
the racial issues you explore
in this movie um center on angie's
biracial
identity and not feeling chinese enough
i wonder if you might address race
differently
if you were to make this movie today oh
wow
that's a really good question um i
definitely think i would
i think that would be a little bit more
painful for her to kind of deal with
like reading about all of these news
reports and really contending and
understanding like how bad systemic
racism racism is in this country i mean
i mean
i know for me kind of hearing about all
of these reports and seeing all these
things has been really eye-opening and
you know it's been tough to deal with so
i think um
it would be a lot more intense for her
if i wrote it um right now
yeah for a teenage girl struggling with
so much already mae really appreciate
you're joining us mae maquino
uh director and writer of in between
girl maddie
and now for today's movers and shakers
the people impacting the world of
business politics and sports
georgia lawmaker marjorie taylor green
says she's gunning for debate with
alexandria ocasio-cortez over the green
new deal
once she's finished all 14 pages of it
rep green says she wants the debate
to be aired on pay-per-view with the
profits split between them
aoc has not confirmed the debate nor
publicly responded to green over the
matter
and heisman winner devonta smith has
signed to be the face of dick's sporting
goods new apparel line
versed marking the first time the
company has put an athlete behind its
private brands
smith will be featured in merchandising
marketing and representation of the
brand
versus aimed at customers of lululemon's
gear
and those are your movers and shakers
from today
staying with sports nba players have
been some of the most outspoken public
figures when it comes to social justice
issues
they led protests after the killing of
george floyd rallied against voter
suppression
and have continued to speak out quick
takes vanessa pradomo spoke with
portland trailblazers
center n.s cantor on his work in social
justice
and how nba players use their platform
to shine the light on these issues
so the last time we spoke was right
after nba players protested games
due to the police shooting of jacob lake
and we just saw
derek chovin was found guilty for
murdering george floyd which is another
police shooting that nba players were
really outspoken against
what is the feeling like amongst players
in the league right now after this
guilty verdict was announced well you
know
like everyone else obviously i follow
the direct children trial like
most of the country not just mba players
but most of the
country you know just a friend and for
justice for
george floyd and obviously um jury you
know find them
guilty on all three uh accounts you know
manslaughter and
uh murder but uh you know they made the
decision pretty
swiftly and the facts were all there and
the evidence was all there
and the powerful video uh the whole
world saw
and we can finally say that
justice was a serve and i think it's a
huge step forward for
you know the social adjustment equality
and
you know i believe uh you know we need
to remember that that is only just uh
one case of uh so so many you know
and you know it begs the question you
know if it were not
for that video would we have this kind
of a sort of
justice you know and so it is well
what it takes so i believe you know
black lives always
matter no matter what so yes i feel like
this was a huge
step forward but i feel like we need to
we need to make a systematic change and
as everyone says and everyone knows and
all them paper
players saying that we have a long fight
ahead of us so we just need to
keep uh pushing and just uh and try to
inspire our young
generation as much as we can how do you
push forward
to make sure that this isn't just a
one-off case that this does continue
to be the verdict if you're an athlete
actor singer rapper or you know if you
have a
platform i feel like we need to use this
platform to inspire as many people we
can especially our young
generation other thing is uh for sure
you know just
there there is a bill out there called
george uh floyd
bill and other other thing is that we we
definitely should
uh push our politicians
senators congressmen congresswomans to
you know just
talk about these issues more and more
because this is only
one case there are so many cases out
there uh
you know so that that's why i feel like
we need to use our
platform to try to spot can
and you do use your platform more than a
lot of people do you're a huge advocate
for human rights
one of the things that you just teamed
up with israeli ambassador gilad erdogan
on a uh op-ed for against anti-semitism
can you tell me how that partnership
came to be and why as someone who's not
jewish you still felt compelled to speak
on this issue
and when i met with ambassador guillermo
obviously he's a huge
basketball fan uh i met him this uh last
uh last uh summer in new york me and him
sit down had an amazing uh conversation
and uh
you know i was like it doesn't matter
what your religion is your background or
your
your skin color or your whatever you are
you know the most important thing in
life is leave your difference on the
table and try to find what we have in
common
because we only have one world to live
you know
and so i was like let's let's bring our
powers together
and try to bring uh you know awareness
of where what's going on
not just anti-semitism but phobia and
and all the other issues around the
world because i feel like we need unity
more than everything you know so that's
why he's in
big basketball and by the way he came to
our game in
miami down to miami and he had an
amazing time so
i'm glad that i have a friend like him
absolutely and speaking of unity in that
way
he's a politician and you're a
professional athlete worlds that
necessarily
a lot of people wouldn't think collide
because politics does
divide a lot of people and sports is
seen as something to bring people
together
so do you think that colliding those
worlds is even more powerful in the
message of unity
of course obviously you know because i
mean uh
i feel like you know he has a huge uh
following and obviously i have a huge
following because of the platform so i
feel like bring those powers
together is definitely creating more
awareness
you know he is a jewish ambassador and a
muslim athlete so when this two
person comes together to to to talk
about unity talk about uh islamophobia
to talk about anti-semitism talk about
what can we do to bring more you know
peace and love
and fight against hate you know people
just stops and say
wow this is very unique we never we've
never seen this kind of
collaboration before so i think it's you
know it's
all about you know uh fighting for uh
one thing and it's
uh it's the fight against hate
anna's thanks so much for joining us and
we'll continue to look for
what you and other athletes do to help
bring social justice issues
forward thank you honestly appreciate it
coming up after the break from carryout
drinks to zoom happy hours
alcohol on demand has become a staple of
the pandemic
we'll hear from one more company that's
delivering drinks straight to your door
this is quick take
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
difference
[Music]
as bars and restaurants closed during
lockdown people definitely didn't stop
drinking
instead they started ordering in bottles
and setting record-breaking alcohol
sales
one company that felt that success
firsthand is drizzly it's an alcohol
delivery service that was acquired by
uber
in a 1.1 billion dollar deal drizzly's
ceo kathy lewinberg joins us now kathy
welcome to quick take i've been very
familiar with drizzly for years and
while i know you grew over 350 percent
over this past year
you were already really successful
before 2020 so
what was it about the uber overture that
made it an offer that you
couldn't pass up because as a standalone
business you seem to be doing just fine
thanks madison that's a great question i
think um we've had a tremendous track
record
over the the last year and we spent
actually a lot of time
in the fall really going deeper on what
our customer wanted from us to
understand what is our next five
six seven ten years look like and as we
dug deeper
it really made sense to have a strategic
partner like uber with both the
technology they bring
certainly their logistic network the
logistics network ubereats platform
so there were just so many synergies it
was an offer we couldn't we couldn't
refuse
so what is that partnership going to
look like or acquisition rather
for the user you know for someone who's
been using drizzly
after this acquisition what what do they
do when they want to order a bottle of
wine
they would still very much come to
drizzly the drizzly brand will remain
in full i think um you know as we think
about the acquisition and what uber's
looking for we certainly bring category
expertise
to the table which they're excited about
but also the grizzly brand which has
really become synonymous with alcohol
e-commerce over the last several years
and so the drizzly brand will remain as
is they can come they can shop for wine
they can shop for
different uh bottles from stores near
them and they can have it delivered in
under an
hour and they'll also be able to do that
from the uber eats platform and so
really just
uh bringing the the ease and convenience
that we offer today to more customers on
more platforms
so it'll still be on both that makes
sense uh and i'm curious about your
relationship with small
businesses as well what does that look
like i think that some would maybe
argue that you know you might want to
just stop by your local wine shop and
pick up a bottle in person imagine that
instead of ordering online so what what
does that relationship look like for you
we have an extensive retailer network of
about 4 500 stores and growing
and it is all about supporting the the
smaller businesses i think that's one of
the really unique things about drizzly
given the complexities with regulations
the elbow industry is just highly
fragmented there's
many independents many mom and pop shops
and we've been able to
through our technology connect a number
of these stores together to create the
drizzly network and so
we've been able to give them a voice be
that digital platform for them to reach
users and to be able to offer
uh new ways to deliver and access
alcohol so
uh we we really partner very closely
with retailers
and are excited to continue to help
support them continue to grow
i think one of the um really interesting
things obviously with uber it's just
going to be able to help us accelerate
that growth for
for our retailer partners with whom we
are so dependent on
another form of discoverability there
now i know that uber bought drizzly and
not
lantern which is the marijuana delivery
platform
uh the plan was to spin it off so what's
the latest for lantern
yeah so the deal actually isn't closed
yet so
drizzly and then lantern roll up to a
parent company so lantern is our sister
company so
we remain uh sister companies today and
at the time with the clothes which we're
expecting in the coming months
lantern will spin off officially and be
a separate company
so i know you probably don't have a lot
of room to talk about this but the uber
ceo has mentioned
interest in the cannabis space what do
you see as the strategy moving down the
road not
only for lantern but with drizzly
regarding marijuana especially as more
and more states legalize
there's no plans at this point for
drizzly to get into the cannabis space
lantern certainly kind of owns that
today
under the drizzly umbrella and i think
we're all excited for the transmission
transformation
we're expecting out of this industry
just given uh the attention it's getting
as more states legalize it we're
expecting kind of big things for lantern
and others that play in the cannabis
space fair enough and one final quick
question for you that is just a
curiosity on my end
what consumption consumption trends are
you noticing from consumers lately and
as we head out of the pandemic has that
changed at all
yeah that's a great one i think you
brought up the virtual zooms uh earlier
which is something we're starting to see
back off but from a consumption trend
standpoint
tequila has been on fire figured i'd
mention and given cinco de mayo is just
weeks away
what was once a seasonal purchase is
much more
irregular and we're seeing beyond the
blank the blancos that the clear
liquids uh a lot of the aged varieties
like the aniejos the reposados also
being purchased we're also seeing flavor
tequilas come to the market 21 seeds is
a great brand to note there
mezcal has just been on fire of 40
year-over-year
uh customers are really loving the
smokiness and also the uniqueness it
brings to cocktails
another big trend we're seeing is hard
seltzer it has been a juggernaut on our
platform for the last couple of years
and we're not seeing that slow down and
in part it's largely being fed by a lot
of the innovation we're seeing so i'm
sure you may have heard of
cacti the brand that launched last month
a partnership between travis barker and
anheuser-busch
set records on the drizzly platform when
we launched it
topo chico also just went live with a
hard seltzer brand that's uh
and it is kind of a new a new segment
within heart seltzer is emerging called
branch water
um and then i think the last one i'll
just note
um ready to drink cocktails that is a
trend
we have seen just take off early in the
pandemic it was very much
caught you know people were kind of
recreating that cocktail culture in
homes
there's bitters spirits on the rise
we've now seen that transition for the
ready to drink cocktails and so
big things in store for heart seltzer
and ready to drink cocktails this summer
all right heading into summer everyone's
cracking their white claws kathy thank
you so much for joining us
scarlett all right heart shelter and
tequila all day coming up after the
break la plans to give some angelinos a
guaranteed income
what impacts will this have on the city
stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
this week los angeles mayor eric
garcetti included a 24 million dollar
basic income guaranteed program in his
city budget
this means la could become one of the
largest cities to try out a program
financially supporting those who can't
make ends meet
joining us to discuss the implications
of the program is bloomberg city labs
sarah holder
who's been covering similar pilot
programs all throughout california
sarah thank you so much for joining us
first off
can you just give me an overview on how
this program in la works
thank you yeah i mean i feel like the
last few months have brought a lot of
new announcements out of california on
the basic income front
but in los angeles mayor eric garcetti
proposed last
week in his city budget to set aside 24
million dollars in next year's
municipal budget for the program which
would send monthly payments of a
thousand dollars to
2000 low-income families in the city and
the way the city would select recipients
is by census tract so he'd target areas
with the highest poverty levels and also
prioritize families
with at least one minor in the family
and those who have suffered some
hardship related to the copen 19
pandemic
so i know that a lot of this is based on
the program that was started by
mayor tubbs out of stockton and we've
been lucky to chat with him on quick
take a couple of times
uh but he wasn't re-elected so
are these mayors concerned at all about
what would happen if they influence the
or they implement these programs and
then they don't get put back in office
they're not successful
yeah i mean every mayor who pursues a
policy like this does open themselves up
to criticism and praise alike you know
especially because these programs are so
small
though las would be one of the biggest
they inherently can't reach everyone
so people who don't get these monthly
payments might not feel the positive
impact of the policy
and you know other critics of
cash payments in general fear that
people won't be spending the money on
the right things so that does
um open up mayors to criticism but i
think
you know in stockton what was
interesting is is results from
the pilot which concluded in january
showed that the folks that did receive
the money had better mental health they
had more time to
spend with their kids um and their
employment was actually 12 percentage
points higher than before they started
getting the payments so despite
you know some of the political
ramifications for tubs it seems like at
least
in the city uh there were ripple effects
right right so we've seen that the
programs have worked in some cases when
it comes to them
in our final minute here it's far
different from ubi can you quickly tell
me one of the biggest differences
between
the two yeah i mean when you think about
universal basic income you rightly think
about monthly cash payments
unconditionally given to everyone rich
and poor
adults across the country and while a
lot of the folks who are advocating for
these city level programs are also
interested in a national legislation the
city level pilots like las are really
focused on targeting to people who need
them the most like lower income people
often with families people that have
been disproportionately impacted
by the pandemic and so they're
inherently targeted but they're still
guaranteed
bloomberg city lab sarah holder thank
you so much for giving us some of your
insights on that scarlet i'm so
interested in the ubi
topic and we loved having mayor tubbs on
to talk about it earlier this year as
well i thought that was a really good
way of explaining the difference between
what la's doing in ubi overall it's
something that
other cities will look into i'm sure yep
absolutely well that does it for quick
take this hour check out our latest
stories at bloomberg.com or
at quicktake on social media have a good
night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
coming up on quick take the lead global
leaders mark earth day 2021 with a
renewed focus on reducing pollution
president biden tries to retake the lead
with a bold pledge
then paris to berlin by train in just an
hour
that could be the future of
transportation and a greener planet
we're talking to the ceo of virgin
hyperloop live about the latest progress
and will the world continue to say
cheers to wine and spirits
after the pandemic we'll take a look at
some big wins and trends in this
industry
it is thursday april 22nd i'm scarlett
fu and i'm madison mills those stories
and more coming up on quick take the
lead
[Music]
happy earth day everyone leaders from 40
nations today
joined president biden for a virtual
summit on climate change biden seeking
to re-establish the us
as a major player on the climate stage
pledging in his opening remarks to cut
the country's greenhouse gas emissions
by
half and boosting aid to developing
nations
we can solve this crisis on our own as i
know you all fully understand
all of us all of us and particularly
those of us who represent
the world's largest economies we have to
step up
so here to help us understand what this
renewed commitment really entails beyond
just stepping up
is bloomberg news power and renewable
energy editor will wade
will great to see you on quick take
biden made some specific promises
a 50 to 52 reduction in u.s greenhouse
gas emissions over the next decade
and a doubling of aid to developing
countries how does this compare to the
us's previous commitment before
trump came along and reversed everything
it's a whole lot more ambitious the
previous commitment that obama
pledged when we signed the paris
agreement five years ago
was 26 to 28 reduction so this is double
that
yeah that so it does sound just by those
numbers alone that this is really taking
the us in a new direction
of course this is politics and biden has
a lot of work to do to convince
the rest of government to go along with
him assuming that he can get congress to
back him on this
how exactly or even generally would the
u.s reach that kind of target 50 to 52
percent
would it replace all the gas guzzling
suvs with electric vehicles i mean what
kind of federal
and state policy changes would need to
be put into place
well there's several basic strategies
the first one
is a lot more clean energy so right now
we get about
40 percent of our energy from carbon
free sources that's nuclear wind and
solar
i've heard that we need to at least
double that to about 80 percent
some people talk about even tripling
that and then once we've got
most of our electricity coming from
clean sources that's when we get to
start
that's what we need to start doing more
things with electricity
like shifting from gasoline cars to
electric cars we need a lot more
electric cars on the road
okay so that's disrupting a lot of
existing industry
potentially angering a lot of
constituents here
john kerry who of course is the white
house's climate change czar
said that other countries when they
heard joe biden's pledge
immediately questioned whether the u.s
can be trusted to deliver on this
promise
especially since president trump had
pulled the u.s out of the paris
agreement
john kerry made the point that the
private sector is already doing
a lot of the work is that really the
case it is
and certainly the us has a big
credibility gap to make up foreign
countries
are rightly skeptical of whether the us
is going to put its money where its
mouth is
but even after trump reversed course
with a lot of federal policies
we saw private businesses we saw cities
we saw states come up with all kinds of
policies and strategies for reducing
emissions so even now
we're about halfway to meeting
the obama pledge of 26 we're about 13
down over about half the time so we're
more or less on track
so we're on track so i suppose you could
make the argument that we could get
there
how exactly did president trump's policy
shifts affect u.s emissions
well the first thing was he tried to
roll back a lot of policy
a lot of rules on emit on coal and
air pollution but it didn't have a huge
effect when it was offset by so much
positive direction from the cities and
states
okay all right so that's interesting and
it's not something that comes up a lot
the hope here is that by setting an
example the u.s will encourage
industrializing nations uh china russia
brazil
india to set their own climate change
targets but china and india are really
not taking the bait as of yet
what is the best argument that
washington the united states can make
that lowering emissions can be growth
positive it will be additive to gdp
rather than something that restrains
growth
well what we've seen in the past is a
lot of companies especially from
you know the status quo industries like
fossil fuel companies talking about how
it would be very expensive to cut
emissions
but what biden is doing and i think this
is really smart is he's pushing it as
an entire economy-wide transition and so
the way to look at that is not how much
is it going to cost
but what are the benefits where where
the job's going to come from
where are you going to be able to make
money by investing in ways to reduce
emissions we already know that
wind and solar installers are like among
the biggest fastest growing jobs in the
country
yeah making the economic argument always
uh gets everyone's attention
well wade thank you so much for joining
us and making us smarter on this really
appreciate it
now staying with all things green we
want to invite you to join our virtual
bloomberg green summit which begins on
monday it's our annual event for the new
climate era on monday you'll
get to hear from former vice president
al gore as well as aerial investments
co-ceo and president
melody hobson be sure to register for
the event at bloomberglive.com
now separately president biden is
looking ahead to his next phase of
reshaping the u.s economy
and to get there he plans to double the
capital gains tax rate for the rich
to almost 40 percent that's according to
people familiar with the proposal
coupled with an existing surtax on
investment income
that means federal tax rates for
millionaire investors
could be as high as 43.4 percent
this proposal could reverse a
long-standing part of the tax code that
has middle-class workers paying
a higher tax rate on their income than
wealthy individuals pay on their
investment income
maddie coming up celebrations sadness
and calls for more
action black lives matter co-founder
opal tometti shares her reflections on
the outcome of the derek chovan trial
in the state of policing in america stay
with us we're back in two
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
while many call the conviction of former
minneapolis police officer
officer derek shovin justice activists
say the fight is far from over
and there's more work to be done earlier
i spoke with black lives matter
co-founder opal tometti about
what it was like to navigate this trial
and why now is the moment to keep moving
forward in addressing
racial injustice
we heard about the verdict convicting
derek chopin in a murder that we know
that he did and so it was almost like
you know reading the weather we knew
that he did it and so having him
held accountable for his actions was
incredibly
important for the millions of people who
rose up and took to the streets around
the world
so i think this for for many of us was
just like a
a real sigh of relief um a real sense of
vindication
something that we knew needed to happen
it was absolutely necessary
and yet the fact that we were sitting on
pins and needles
for you know weeks on end wondering
whether or not this man
would be found guilty was um is also
deeply disturbing it speaks to some of
the
challenges in our society and challenges
this policing overall
so you know i say first you know i'm
glad i'm
glad he was found guilty that was the
right thing on all charges
and then secondly i would be remiss if i
didn't mention that there are
many other people who have been killed
but at the hands of police
during that trial and so we know that
the challenges
are profound they're systemic um it's
not just a one and done this is not a
transformative moment
this is one
incident where we're finally seeing
accountability
yet true justice would require the
system change
of course the day of the derek chauvin
verdict we heard about
micaiah bryant who's fatally shot by
police officers in columbus ohio today
is dante wright's funeral
the list of names unending
what does that rapid succession of names
mean to you
about policing in america
sadly it's a testament to the fact that
our work
is far from over you know we started
black lives matter
over 70 years ago now and clearly
the work yes has gained momentum yes
more visibility yes
you know more notoriety and public
praise and acclaim
and nobel prize nomination and all those
sorts of things
yet the fact is if black people can
still be
you know gunned down in the street they
can still uh be killed with impunity
we still have a real systemic challenge
on our hands and we're going to need
real
uh transformative policy changes in
order to address that
and to me seeing those names and hearing
the stories
just this past week week and a half two
weeks
has broken my heart and we can't seem to
even really rest and celebrate
the the verdict before getting another
story of a young black girl
being killed at the hands of police
what kind of work do you think needs to
be done to really
put a stop to the police brutality that
we've seen again time and time again in
this country
black communities deserve to be invested
in we need
job opportunities we need health
services
we need mental health uh first
responders
we need other types of solutions that
look at black
people with the respect and the dignity
that they deserve we're of course
hearing calls to
abolish or defund the police with many
saying after the verdict that abolition
was the mission
where do you sit with that my hope
is that we continue to ask the tough
questions to be grown-ups
and to do the work of transforming our
society where we can have
a multi-racial democracy that works for
all of us
and so it's step by step and i i hope
that we will see
a world in which we we don't need police
anymore right where
we see and we are defining safety in a
more broad
and comprehensive way where we're
looking at solutions to challenges on
our community
um in a more dignified manner and i
think we can do that
but i do think that's gonna take you
know that's gonna take commitment it's
gonna take experimentation
and just like we've invested you know
billions of dollars in one arena i say
like why don't we
take those resources and begin to
experiment with other solutions
that might be out there that we haven't
tested we haven't
given them the opportunity to try out in
all of these years
clearly this isn't working clearly we've
seen we've seen
what is going on we see the status quo
and you know it's enough it's time to
try something new
can't thank you enough for joining us we
we so appreciate it thank you so so much
thank you
thank you
we'll have more of our conversation with
opal on at quick take on social media if
you want to watch more in scarlet one
thing that she also mentioned earlier
that i found to be so profound was just
this feeling of exhaustion this
verdict coming out she hasn't stopped
working since you know she hasn't slept
and uh just got the sense from her that
she feels like there's so much left to
continue to do
yeah it was a relief in so many ways
just it marked an
a turning point but also as you
mentioned a signal that there's a new
chapter to to forge
on this all right we want to turn our
attention now in the meantime to the
pandemic
and we'll start with india whose numbers
on covet 19 deaths are currently at odds
with the bodies piling up at
crematoriums and burial grounds
so that leaves a data gap that could
keep india unprepared to fight renewed
outbreaks
india reported almost 315 000 new cases
today the world's highest ever daily
tally
by comparison the u.s saw a peak of just
over 314 thousand cases
back on december 21st and the new surge
in covet infections is threatening to
further divide the global economy
between the rich
and the poor and it could damage overall
global growth if the fresh outbreak
spread
or if key sources of demand falter
more people were diagnosed no i can't
get my words out today were diagnosed
with covid last week than any other time
since the pandemic began to get a better
sense of where in the world covet is
spreading and to track the global
inoculation effort
visit bloomberg.com forward slash
coronavirus a wealth of information
there
maddie coming up after the break the
road to innovation
may help improve your travel time and
climate change
we'll explain when we get back into
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
this is the difference
[Music]
[Music]
replacing gas guzzling cars with greener
vehicles is certainly one way to reduce
our carbon footprint
but the future of transportation is
still very much a work in progress
and one possible step forward is
hyperloop it's a new technology that
promises to be time efficient
and cleaner for the environment it's in
development by a number of companies
including virgin hyperloop whose ceo and
co-founder josh geigel
joins us now josh good to see you on
quick take thank you for joining us
to start us off for those who aren't
familiar with it briefly explain what
hyperloop is we know that elon musk is
very excited about it
or at least he was a couple years ago
but tell us how it works and what kind
of carbon footprint it leaves
we're still very excited about here but
hyperloop's a new form of transportation
it's taking you directly to your
destination without stopping at any
place along the way
and doing that in a i'll say at the
speed of an aircraft
without all the emissions that are
associated with flight
and so we're able to do that by having a
onboard propulsed vehicle
we're able to do that with having
batteries on board and then when you
show up to a station or show up to a
portal
you go when you want to go you're not
waiting you know hours for a train or a
plane to go
and the real i think exciting point of
this for us
is this idea of sustainability without
sacrifice
so the point that we can basically go
the speed of an aircraft
not have to wait but also do that for a
fraction of the emissions about 10 times
less energy than an aircraft
okay so it sounds amazing and these
simulations are incredible i mean any
transportation fan and anyone who cares
about the environment
would just be taken by it last november
virgin hyperloop ran its first crude
ride
in the desert outside of las vegas now i
believe you were on there
it's still though very much a concept
where is the u.s government
in terms of actually writing rules for
it and investing in it
i think this is the opportunity that we
see with the pandemic we're seeing you
know the biden administration put out an
infrastructure plan
this idea build back better we want to
create the future based on technology
that will help us solve
problems we can't continue to use
technology from last century to solve
the problems that we have today climate
change and the like i mean i don't use a
computer from 1980
so i shouldn't use a transportation
system from 1960 or even 1920
and so if we're going to buy some or
build something new build something
better when you look at
creating new infrastructure for people
we want them to have a better experience
than
they have now which is going to be an
aircraft and then doing that in a way
that's responsible
for us and then for our future
generations okay i understand all of
that but a lot of work needs to be done
the really boring bureaucratic work that
governments need to undertake and if
anything my understanding is that
it's farther along in places like europe
which has already started setting
standards and regulations
walk us through the steps needed to make
hyperloop commercially viable
in europe so to make it viable what we
have to go is actually develop the
technology as you saw we did a test i
was in that with my colleague sarah
and we were the first passenger test and
we have to take that two passenger
vehicle we have to move that to
about a 28 passenger commercial vehicle
we're doing that
in our facilities in los angeles and las
vegas in conjunction with that
you're developing the rule sets with
independent safety assessors the same
way that europe does trains
we've actually done that with the
passenger test that we did before
and continuing to do that as we go
forward so this idea of an independent
third party
that makes it i'll say deemed safe
that's what the regulator is actually
looking for and that's how we intend to
take this to market
both in europe and across the world you
mentioned uh trains in europe does
hyperloop get us closer to high-speed
rail which is something else that a lot
of environmentalists
in the u.s talk about i think it's it's
actually way more than getting us closer
to high-speed rail blows it away
so you're able to go three times as fast
you're able to do that when you want
you're not having to deal with other
vehicles on the track or things crossing
it or whether
you're in an enclosed tube you're going
at the speed of an aircraft and
on an on-demand setting so your vehicle
is going direct to your destination it's
not stopping
at every place along the way so it's not
just recreating rail it's actually
leaving rail behind and moving forward
to what
we should experience for on-demand
transportation in this century
so along with virgin hyperloop there are
a number of different companies working
on the technology on the form of
transportation
i just did a quick check and i've seen
up to 15. what do you say to critics who
make the argument that the technology
will never work but the research that's
being put into it is still very valuable
i think just wait just wait for us to
show you i mean they told us we couldn't
start a company they told us we couldn't
build a system they told us it couldn't
be safe for passengers and we've done
all those you know i think the the
opportunity
to build a brand new system that's what
we're doing right now and plenty of
people said you couldn't land a rocket
and people didn't build a plane and yet
here we are today with planes and
rockets that land themselves so
i think it's just a matter of time
technology will be able to solve it all
josh quick question for you before we
say goodbye um is elon musk
positive or negative for hyperloop
overall i mean he
obviously has weighed in in the past but
he's not doing anything with it beyond
heading a boring company which you know
drills those tunnels
i can't comment for elin himself but i
do know if he has an idea he usually
sees it through
and i think we're taking up that mantle
of really taking that idea to the next
level and trying to put it out there so
i hope he's hope he's excited about what
the future looks like
geigel ceo of co-founder of virgin
hyperloop thank you so much for joining
us really appreciate your time
maddie sticking with climate change a
global problem
at the local level in this week's city
lab segment we're taking a look at how
big cities are adapting as they're
increasingly threatened by coastal
flooding
quick takes matthew albany spoke with
city labs linda poon to find out more
so linda first off thank you for joining
us i know one of the main things that
you talk about in your store are cities
with an estimated more than half the
world's population living in some sort
of urban environment
how exactly are cities impacting climate
change
right so people in cities are always
moving right they're commuting they're
working they're using
energy to heat their homes hit their
office or cool their office
summer times coming over here in the u.s
so that means cities are constantly
using energy and they're one of the
major contributors to global greenhouse
gas emissions
um which you know contributes to climate
change
um in which cities are uniquely
vulnerable to its effect
so at the same time though because
there are so many people living in
cities and there's going to be even more
people living over the next few decades
there is this urgency to make cities the
forefront
of curbing climate change um so there
are a lot of efforts out there to
you know cut greenhouse gas emissions to
make cities greener and more efficient
basically to mitigate the impacts of
global warming
right and i i wanted to speak to some of
those points i know you talked about it
as a 15-minute city
in your piece that you talk about um
what are some of the ways that you know
some of these cities are trying to
mitigate
the impacts that they're having yeah so
with the 15-minute city concept
um the whole point is to
sort of reduce car use right traffic is
the second largest contributor to
greenhouse gas emissions
so there is real incentives and what 50
minute city
does is essentially make neighborhoods
self-sufficient so
the idea is that you live 15 minutes by
bike
or by public transportation or even by
foot
to everything you need your job your
hospital
your school and that way if you don't
need a drive then you have
you know less reason to and and in that
way
cities are able to sort of cut carbon
emissions
but other than that cities are also very
focused on
cutting building emissions right
building emissions are actually the
number one
contributor to greenhouse gas in cities
that means making buildings more energy
efficient
heating and cooling takes up a lot of
energy
and in older buildings which you know
some of these cities are historic
there's a lot of need to renovate them
and to make them
basically um greener interesting and so
is this something that we're seeing
mainly one country doing
in isolated areas or is this more of a
global effort
in ways to help reduce the impact yeah
so for sure it's a global effort right
you have hundreds of cities that sign
onto the paris agreement
in 2015 with the goal of lowering
or sorry of keeping uh global heating to
below two degrees celsius so there is
this understanding
that you know cities all over the world
have to work together in order to make
some sort of difference and and cities
really are leading the way
you have cities in u.s who are
completely changing the building codes
new york city has one of the most
stringent building codes now
in order to make buildings more
efficient cities in europe
basically paris is spearheading this
15-minute city idea and it's encouraging
a lot of other european cities and u.s
cities to
follow suit in china there they're
trying to electrify public transit
in order to reduce traffic congestion
right and and the
and the carbon emissions that come from
traffic congestion so it's a huge city
effort
you have organizations like cdp um
tracking the
progress and you have coalitions like
c40 that are
you know making sure that leaders are
following through
with the targets that they set obviously
a fight against mother nature is very
difficult the strength before for cities
was that they were able to be along the
coasts
be these hubs these ports are there any
ways that these cities are trying to
you know prevent any of the disastrous
measures that could happen with the
impact of
climate change yeah so if coastal cities
flooding from sea level rise is the
biggest threat
is the threat right and it's sort of
inevitable it's it's a question of how
much we can stop sea level rise right
and in time post flooding is happening
right now
what cities are doing are are trying to
mitigate the effects
so you have some cities use more
traditional method like flood barriers
and sea walls so
if you look at venice venice is set to
complete a billion dollar
flood barrier project um that is
expected to hold back water during high
tide
um and it's a very controversial project
in terms of
its efficiency and and the and the price
tag um so
so cities are trying different ways and
it's it's a question of
whether these are going to work in the
long term here in the u.s
researchers are already predicting you
have possibly 13 million people moving
away from the coast because of flooding
over the next few years
well i think it's safe to say now more
than ever the entire world is watching
so bloomberg's linda poon thank you so
much once again for a fantastic
reporting and taking time out of your
day to talk to us
thank you so much for having me
we're going to switch gears now because
coming up after the break a cunning
coming-of-age story that just makes
sense in 2021 we speak with writer and
director may makino about her new film
in between girl
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
here's what a coming-of-age movie looks
like in 2021
an awkward teenage girl grappling with
racial identity a love triangle and a
broken family
all under the glare of social media it's
a pretty far cry from the teen movies of
the 90s and the early millennium
in-between girl which premiered at south
by southwest last month hits
all the notes of a modern coming-of-age
tale and more
so i want to welcome the film's writer
and director mae makino now
congratulations on winning the audience
award in the visions category at south
by
mae this was your first feature film i
want to
start by asking how much of it was based
on you because
you definitely share some similarities
with the lead character angie in that
you're both biracial and you're both
artists
yeah um so of course quite a bit um of
angie is based on me
you know i think all the characters kind
of come from me
in some weird way whether that's just
like their insecurities
or kind of their quirks but i think
angie for sure
um there were like a lot of things i
think
just being biracial and kind of having
to deal with
kind of fitting into two different
cultures and kind of feeling out of
place
and you know growing up i think um it
was hard for me
to kind of feel a part of a lot of
things um
and so that that element was definitely
kind of based on my life
at one point i read that you wrote angie
as half mexican in half black
that was your first draft why did you
decide first of all to go in that
direction
yeah so growing up you know i very much
had angie's experience
i was like the only um
person of color um at a white
episcopalian school
um and so i didn't grow up with a lot of
like asian friends unfortunately
but i did have like a lot of black um
and hispanic friends and then i had a
lot of like
black and hispanic students when i
taught filmmaking
and so you know i think i was just like
okay i'll just write a character kind of
based on them
um and i i've said this before but i
think it was
you know i it was easier for me to write
about it like kind of wearing
kind of a mask um but then we decided to
kind of
open auditions up to anyone who is
non-white
and emma galbraith who plays angie
is half white and half chinese and she
was just amazing
interesting how you pivoted based on the
talent that you attracted i really
appreciate your sharing that story about
wearing a mask what i love about this
movie is that it's extremely female
positive
the popular girl is not really a mean
girl there's conflict and tension
between angie and the other secondary
female characters
but there's also a lot of relating and
learning as well
was this an intentional pushback against
um female characters that you had seen
depicted in teen movies when you were
growing up
oh absolutely i think um you know a lot
of
what i grew up with um was kind of like
teen movies where the goal was to get
the guy at any cost
um and you know a lot of times like
something like
16 candles comes to mind you know
like jake ryan is totally awful to his
blonde girlfriend he kind of just gives
her away when she's drunk
um to the nerd and watching that was
like kind of really terrible
and i wanted to kind of show what i had
grown up with which was
a lot of times like the women i had been
jealous of were really really cool
and i ended up being really great
friends with them now you started
writing this script in 2017
it premiered as i mentioned earlier this
year right as reports of anti-asian
violence were picking up and by the way
the senate voted to
pass the hate crimes bill and it now is
going to the house
most of the racial issues you explore in
this movie center on
angie's biracial identity and not
feeling chinese enough
i wonder if you might address race
differently if you were to make this
movie today
oh wow that's a really good question
um i definitely think i would i think
that would be a little bit more painful
for
her to kind of deal with like reading
about all of these news reports and
really contending and
understanding like how bad systemic
racism
racism is in this country i mean i mean
i know for me
kind of hearing about all of these
reports and seeing all these things has
been really eye-opening and
you know it's been tough to deal with so
i think um
it would be a lot more intense for her
if i wrote it um
right now yeah for a teenage girl
struggling with so much already
mae really appreciate your joining us
mae makino
director and writer of in between girl
maddie
and now for today's movers and shakers
the people impacting the world of
business politics and sports
georgia lawmaker marjorie taylor green
says she's gunning for debate with
alexandria ocasio-cortez over the green
new deal
once she's finished all 14 pages of it
rep green says she wants the debate to
be aired on pay-per-view with the
profits split between them
aoc has not confirmed the debate nor
publicly responded to green over the
matter
and heisman winner devonta smith has
signed to be the face of dick's sporting
goods new apparel line
first marking the first time the company
has put an athlete behind its private
brands
smith will be featured in merchandising
marketing and representation of the
brand
versus aimed at customers of lululemons
gear
and those are your movers and shakers
from today
staying with sports nba players have
been some of the most outspoken public
figures when it comes to social justice
issues
they led protests after the killing of
george floyd rallied against voter
suppression
and have continued to speak out quick
takes vanessa pradomo spoke with
portland trailblazers
center n.s cantor on his work in social
justice
and how nba players use their platform
to shine the light on these issues
so the last time we spoke was right
after nba players protested games
due to the police shooting of jacob lake
and we just saw
derek chovin was found guilty for
murdering george floyd which is another
police shooting that nba players were
really outspoken against
what is the feeling like amongst players
in the league right now after this
guilty verdict was announced well you
know
like everyone else obviously i followed
the derrick children trial like uh most
of the
country not just the mba players but
most of the country
you know just a friend and for justice
for george floyd and obviously
um jury you know find them guilty on all
three
accounts you know manslaughter and uh
murder
but uh you know they made the decision
pretty
swiftly and the facts were all there and
the evidence was all there
and the powerful video uh the whole
world so and we can finally
say that justice was a serve and i think
it's a huge step forward for
you know the social justice equality and
you know i believe uh you know we need
to remember that that is only just
uh one case of uh so so
many you know and you know it begs the
question you know
if it were not for that video would we
have this
kind of a sort of justice you know
and so it is well what it takes so i
believe
you know black lives always matter no
matter what
so yes i feel like this was a huge step
forward but
i feel like we need to we need to make a
systematic
change and as everyone says and everyone
knows and all them vapor
players saying that we have a long fight
ahead of us so we just need to
keep pushing and just talk and try to
inspire our young
generation as much as we can how do you
push forward
to make sure that this isn't just a
one-off case that this does continue
to be the verdict if you're an athlete
actor singer rapper or you know if you
have a
platform i feel like we need to use this
platform to inspire as many people we
can especially our young
generation the other thing is uh for
sure you know just
there is a bill out there
we definitely should uh push our
politicians
senators congressmen congresswomans to
you know just
talk about these issues more and more
because this is only
one case there are so many cases out
there uh
you know so that that's why i feel like
we need to use our
platform to try this fight as much as we
can
and you do use your platform more than a
lot of people do you're a huge advocate
for human rights
one of the things that you just teamed
up with israeli ambassador gilad erdogan
on a op-ed for against anti-semitism
can you tell me how that partnership
came to be and why as someone who's not
jewish you still felt compelled to speak
on this issue and when i
met with ambassador gillard obviously
he's a huge
basketball fan i met him this last
last summer in new york me and him
sit down had an amazing conversation
and uh you know i was like it doesn't
matter what your religion is your
background or your
your skin color or your whatever you are
you know the most important thing in
life is leave your difference on the
table and try to find what we have in
common
because we only have one world to live
you know
and so i was like let's let's bring our
powers together
and try to bring uh you know awareness
of where what's going on
not just anti-semitism but phobia and
and all the other issues around the
world because i feel like we need
unity more than everything you know so
that's why he's in big basketball and uh
by the way he came to our game in uh
uh miami down to uh miami and he had an
amazing time so
i'm glad that i have a friend like him
absolutely and speaking of unity in that
way
he's a politician and you're a
professional athlete worlds that
necessarily
a lot of people wouldn't think collide
because politics does
divide a lot of people and sports is
seen as something to bring people
together
so do you think that colliding those
worlds is even more powerful in the
message of unity
of course obviously you know because i
mean uh
i feel like you know he has a huge uh
following and obviously i have a huge
following because of the nba platform so
i feel like bring those powers
together is definitely creating more
awareness
you know he is a jewish ambassador and a
muslim athlete so when this two
person comes together to to to talk
about unity talk about uh islamophobia
to talk about anti-semitism talk about
what can we do to bring more you know
peace and love
and fight against hate you know people
just stops and say wow this is very
unique we never
we've never seen this kind of
collaboration before so i think it's you
know it's
it's all about you know uh fighting for
uh
one thing and it's uh it's the
fight against hate uh thanks so much for
joining us and we'll
continue to look for what you and other
athletes do to help bring
social justice issues forward thank you
honestly appreciate it
coming up after the break from carry out
drinks to zoom happy hours
alcohol on demand has become a staple of
the pandemic
we'll hear from one more company that's
delivering drinks straight to your door
this is quick take
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as bars and restaurants closed during
lockdown people
definitely didn't stop drinking instead
they started ordering in bottles and
setting
record-breaking alcohol sales one
company that felt that success firsthand
is drizzly it's an alcohol delivery
service that was acquired by uber
in a 1.1 billion dollar deal drizzly's
ceo kathy lewinberg joins us now kathy
welcome to quick take i've been very
familiar with drizzly for years and
while i know you grew
over 350 percent over this past year
you were already really successful
before 2020 so
what was it about the uber overture that
made it an offer that you
couldn't pass up because as a standalone
business you seem to be doing just fine
thanks madison that that's a great
question i think um we've had a
tremendous track record over
the the last year and we spent actually
a lot of time in the fall
really going deeper on what our customer
wanted from us to understand what does
our next five
six seven ten years look like and as we
dug deeper
it really made sense to have a strategic
partner like uber with both the
technology they bring
certainly their logistic network the
logistics network ubereats platform
so there were just so many synergies it
was an offer we couldn't we couldn't
refuse
so what is that partnership going to
look like or acquisition rather
for the user you know for someone who's
been using drizzly
after this acquisition what what do they
do when they want to order a bottle of
wine
they would still very much come to
drizzly the drizzly bland brand will
remain
in full i think um you know as we think
about the acquisition and what uber's
looking for we certainly bring category
expertise
to the table which they're excited about
but also the grizzly brand which has
really become synonymous with alcohol
e-commerce over the last several years
and so the drizzly brand will remain as
is they can come they can shop for wine
they can shop for different
bottles from stores near them and they
can have it delivered in under an
hour and they'll also be able to do that
from the ubereats platform and so really
just
uh bringing the the ease and convenience
that we offer today to more customers on
more platforms so it'll still be on both
that makes sense
uh and i'm curious about your
relationship with small businesses
as well what does that look like i think
that some would maybe
argue that you know you might want to
just stop by your local wine shop and
pick up a bottle in person
imagine that instead of ordering online
so what
what does that relationship look like
for you
we have an extensive retailer network of
about 4 500 stores and growing
and it is all about supporting the the
smaller businesses i think that's one of
the really unique things about drizzly
given the complexities with regulations
the algol industry is just highly
fragmented there's
many independents many mom-and-pop shops
and we've been able to
through our technology connect a number
of these stores together to create the
drizzly network and so
we've been able to give them a voice be
that digital
platform for them to reach users and to
be able to offer
uh new ways to deliver and access
alcohol so
we we really partner very closely with
retailers
and are excited to continue to help
support them continue to grow
i think one of the um really interesting
things obviously with uber it's just
going to be able to help us accelerate
that growth for our poor retailer
partners with whom
we are so dependent on another form of
discoverability there
now i know that uber bought drizzly and
not lantern which is the
marijuana delivery platform the plan was
to spin it off so what's the latest for
lantern
yeah so the deal actually isn't closed
yet so
drizzly and then lantern roll up to a
parent company so lantern is our sister
company so
we remain uh sister companies today and
at the time with the close which we're
expecting in the coming months
lantern will spin off uh officially and
be a separate company
so i know you probably don't have a lot
of room to talk about this but the uber
ceo has mentioned interest in the
cannabis space
what do you see as the strategy moving
down the road not only for lantern but
with drizzly
regarding marijuana especially as more
and more states legalize
there's no plans at this point for
drizzly to get into the cannabis space
lantern certainly kind of owns that
today
under the drizzly umbrella and i think
we're all excited for the transmission
transformation we're expecting
out of this industry just given uh the
attention it's getting
as more states legalize it we're
expecting kind of big things for lantern
and others that play in the cannabis
space
fair enough and one final quick question
for you that is just a curiosity on my
end
what can some consumption trends are you
noticing from consumers lately and as we
head out of the pandemic has that
changed at all
yeah that's a great one i think um you
brought up the virtual zooms uh earlier
which is something we're starting to see
back off but from a consumption trend
standpoint
tequila has been on fire figured i'd
mentioned and given cinco de mayo is
just weeks away
uh what was once a seasonal purchase is
much more irregular and we're seeing
beyond the blank the blancos that the
clear liquids
uh a lot of the aged varieties like the
aniejos the reposados
also being purchased we're also seeing
flavor tequilas come to the market 21
seeds is a great brand to note there
mezcal has just been on fire of 40 year
over year
uh customers are really loving the
smokiness and also the uniqueness it
brings to cocktails
another big trend we're seeing is hard
seltzer it has been a juggernaut on our
platform for the last couple of years
and we're not seeing that slow down and
in part it's largely being fed by a lot
of the innovation we're seeing so i'm
sure you may have heard of
cacti the brand that launched last month
a partnership between travis barker and
anheuser-busch
set records on the drizzly platform when
we launched it
topo chico also just went live with a
hard seltzer brand that's uh
and it is kind of a new a new segment
within heart seltzer's emerging called
ranch water
um and then i think the last one i'll
just note
um ready to drink cocktails that is a
trend
we have seen just take off early in the
pandemic it was very much
you know people were kind of recreating
that cocktail culture in homes so we saw
there's bitters spirits on the rise
we've now seen that transition order
though ready to drink cocktails and so
big things in store for hard seltzer and
ready to drink cocktails this summer
all right heading into summer everyone's
cracking their white claws kathy thank
you so much for joining us
scarlett all right hard seltzer and
tequila all day coming up after the
break
la plans to give some angelinos a
guaranteed income
what impacts will this have on the city
stay with us
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
this week los angeles mayor eric
garcetti included a 24 million dollar
basic income guaranteed program in his
city budget
this means la could become one of the
largest cities to try out a program
financially supporting those who can't
make ends meet
joining us to discuss the implications
of the program is bloomberg city lab's
sarah holder
who's been covering similar pilot
programs all throughout california
sarah thank you so much for joining us
first off
can you just give me an overview on how
this program in la works
thank you yeah i mean i feel like the
last few months have brought a lot of
new announcements out of california on
the basic income front
but in los angeles mayor eric garcetti
proposed last week in his city budget to
set aside
24 million dollars in next year's
municipal budget for the program which
would send monthly payments of a
thousand dollars
to 2000 low-income families in the city
and the way the city would select
recipients is by census tract so he'd
target areas with the highest poverty
levels and also prioritize families
with at least one minor in the family
and those who have suffered some
hardship related to the copen19 pandemic
so i know that a lot of this is based on
the program that was started by
mayor tubbs out of stockton and we've
been lucky to chat with him on quick
take a couple of times
uh but he wasn't re-elected so
are these mayors concerned at all about
what would happen if they influence the
or
they implement these programs and then
they don't get put back in office
they're not successful
yeah i mean every mayor who pursues a
policy like this does open themselves up
to criticism
and praise alike you know especially
because these programs are so small
though las would be one of the biggest
they inherently can't reach everyone
so people who don't get these monthly
payments might not feel the positive
impact of the policy
and you know other critics of um
cash payments in general fear that
people won't be spending the money on
the right things so that does um
open up mayors to criticism but i think
you know in stockton what was
interesting is is results from
the pilot which concluded in january
showed that the folks that did receive
the money had better mental health they
had more time to
spend with their kids and their
employment was actually 12 percentage
points higher than before they started
getting the payments so despite
you know some of the political
ramifications for tubs it seems like at
least
in the city right uh there were ripple
effects
right right so we've seen that the
programs have worked in some cases when
it comes to them in our final minute
here
it's far different from ubi can you
quickly tell me one of the biggest
differences between the two yeah i mean
when you think about universal basic
income you rightly think about monthly
cash payments unconditionally given to
everyone
rich and poor adults across the country
and while a lot of the folks who are
advocating for these city level programs
are also interested in a national
legislation
the city level pilots like la's are
really focused on targeting to people
who need them the most like lower income
people
often with families people that have
been disproportionately impacted
by the pandemic and so they're
inherently targeted but they're still
guaranteed bloomberg city lab sarah
holder thank you so much for giving us
some of your insights
on that scarlett i'm so interested in
the ubi topic and
we loved having mayor tubbs on to talk
about it earlier this year as well i
thought that was a really good way of
explaining the difference between what
la's doing in ubi overall it's something
that
other cities will look into i'm sure yep
absolutely well that does it for quick
take this hour check out our latest
stories at bloomberg.com or at quicktake
on social media
have a good night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg start exploring
to see what's moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
coming up on quick take the lead global
leaders mark earth day 2021 with a
renewed focus on reducing pollution
president biden tries to retake the lead
with a bold pledge
then paris to berlin by train in just an
hour that could be the future of
transportation and a greener planet
we're talking to the ceo of virgin
hyperloop live about the latest progress
and will the world continue to say
cheers to wine and spirits
after the pandemic we'll take a look at
some big wins and trends in this
industry
it is thursday april 22nd i'm scarlett
fu and i'm madison mills those stories
and more coming up on quick take the
lead
[Music]
happy earth day everyone leaders from 40
nations today
joined president biden for a virtual
summit on climate change biden seeking
to re-establish the us as a major player
on the climate stage
pledging in his opening remarks to cut
the country's greenhouse
gas emissions by half and boosting aid
to developing nations
we can solve this crisis on our own as i
know you all fully understand
all of us all of us and particularly
those of us who represent
the world's largest economies we have to
step up
so here to help us understand what this
renewed commitment really entails beyond
just stepping up
is bloomberg news power and renewable
energy editor will
wade will great to see you on quick take
biden made some specific promises a 50
to 52
reduction in u.s greenhouse gas
emissions over the next decade and a
doubling of aid to developing countries
how does this compare to the us's
previous commitment before trump came
along
and reversed everything it's a whole lot
more ambitious the previous commitment
that obama
pledged when we signed the paris
agreement five years ago
was 26 to 28 percent reduction so this
is double that
yeah that so it does sound just by those
numbers alone that this is really taking
the us in a new direction
of course this is politics and biden has
a lot of work to do to convince
the rest of government to go along with
him assuming that he can get
congress to back him on this how exactly
or even generally would the u.s reach
that kind of target 50 to 52 percent
would it replace all the gas guzzling
suvs with electric vehicles i mean what
kind of federal and state policy changes
would need to be put into place
well there's several basic strategies
the first one
is a lot more clean energy so right now
we get about
40 percent of our energy from carbon
free sources that's nuclear wind and
solar
i've heard that we need to at least
double that to about 80 percent
some people talk about even tripling
that and then once we've got most of our
electricity coming from clean sources
that's when we get to start that's when
we need to start doing more things
with electricity like shifting from
gasoline cars to electric cars we need a
lot more electric cars on the road
okay so that's disrupting a lot of
existing industry
potentially angering a lot of
constituents here
john kerry who of course is the white
house house's climate changes are
said that other countries when they
heard joe biden's pledge
immediately questioned whether the u.s
can be trusted to deliver on this
promise
especially since president trump had
pulled the u.s out of the paris
agreement
john kerry made the point that the
private sector is already doing a lot of
the work
is that really the case it is and
certainly the u.s has a big credibility
gap to make up foreign countries
are rightly skeptical of whether the u.s
is going to put its money where its
mouth
is but even after trump reversed course
with a lot of federal policies
we saw private businesses we saw cities
we saw states come up with all kinds of
policies and strategies for reducing
emissions so even now
we're about halfway to meeting
the obama pledge of 26 we're about 13
down over about half the time so we're
more or less on track
so we're on track so i suppose you could
make the argument that we could get
there
how exactly did president trump's policy
shifts affect u.s emissions
well the first thing was he tried to
roll back a lot of policy
a lot of rules on emit on coal and
air pollution but it didn't have a huge
effect when it was offset by so much
positive direction from the cities and
states
okay all right so that's interesting and
it's not something that comes up a lot
the hope here is that by setting an
example the us will encourage
industrializing nations
uh china russia brazil india to set
their own climate change targets but
china and india are really not taking
the bait as of yet
what is the best argument that
washington the united states can make
that lowering emissions can be growth
positive it will be additive to gdp
rather than something that restrains
growth well what we've seen in the past
is a lot of companies especially from
you know the status quo industries like
fossil fuel companies talking about how
it would be very expensive to cut
emissions
but what biden is doing and i think this
is really smart is he's pushing it
as an entire economy-wide transition
and so the way to look at that is not
how much is it going to cost
but what are the benefits where the jobs
going to come from
where are you going to be able to make
money by investing in ways to reduce
emissions we already know that wind and
solar installers are like
among the biggest fastest growing jobs
in the country yeah making the economic
argument always
gets everyone's attention well wade
thank you so much for joining us and
making us smarter on this really
appreciate it
now staying with all things green we
want to invite you to join our virtual
bloomberg green summit which begins on
monday
it's our annual event for the new
climate era on monday you'll
get to hear from former vice president
al gore as well as ariel investments
co-ceo and president
melody hobson be sure to register for
the event at bloomberglive.com
now separately president biden is
looking ahead to his next phase of
reshaping the us economy
and to get there he plans to double the
capital gains tax rate for the rich to
almost 40 percent
that's according to people familiar with
the proposal coupled with an existing
surtax on investment income
that means federal tax rates for
millionaire investors
could be as high as 43.4 percent
this proposal could reverse a
long-standing part of the tax code that
has middle-class workers paying
a higher tax rate on their income than
wealthy individuals pay on their
investment income
maddie coming up celebrations sadness
and calls for more
action black lives matter co-founder
opal tometti shares her reflections on
the outcome of the derrick chauvin trial
in the state of policing in america stay
with us we're back in two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
while many call the conviction of former
minneapolis police officer
officer derek shovin justice activists
say the fight is far from over
and there's more work to be done earlier
i spoke with black lives matter
co-founder opal tometti about
what it was like to navigate this trial
and why now is the moment to keep moving
forward in addressing racial injustice
we heard about the verdict convicting
derek chopin in a murder that we know
that he did and so it was almost like
you know reading the weather we knew
that he did it and so having him held
accountable
for his actions was incredibly important
for the
millions of people who rose up and took
to the streets around the world
so i think this for for many of us was
just like a
a real sigh of relief um a real sense of
vindication
something that we knew needed to happen
it was absolutely
necessary and yet the fact that we were
sitting on pins and needles
for you know weeks on end wondering
whether or not this man
would be found guilty was um is also
deeply disturbing
it speaks to some of the challenges in
our society and challenges this policing
overall
so you know i'd say first you know i'm
glad i'm glad he was found guilty that
was the right thing on all charges
and then secondly i would be remiss if i
didn't mention that there are
many other people who have been killed
but at the hands of police
during that trial and so we know that
the challenges
are profound they're systemic it's not
just a one-and-done this is not a
transformative moment this is one
um incident where we are finally seeing
accountability um yet true justice would
require
the system change of course the day of
the derek chauvin verdict
we heard about mikaya bryant who's
fatally shot by police officers in
columbus ohio today is dante wright's
funeral
the list of names unending
what does that rapid succession of names
mean to you
about policing in america
sadly it's a testament to the fact that
our work
is far from over you know we started
black lives matter
over 70 years ago now and clearly
the work yes has gained momentum yes
more visibility yes
you know more notoriety and public
praise and acclaim and
nobel prize nomination and all those
sorts of things
yet the fact is if black people can
still be
you know gunned down in the street they
can still uh be killed with impunity
we still have a real systemic challenge
on our hands and we're going to need
real
uh transformative policy changes in
order to address that
and to me seeing those names and hearing
the stories
just this past week week and a half two
weeks
has broken my heart and we can't seem to
even really rest and celebrate the the
verdict
before getting another story of a young
black girl
being killed at the hands of police
what kind of work do you think needs to
be done to really
put a stop to the police brutality that
we've seen again time and time again in
this country
black communities deserve to be invested
in we need
job opportunities we need health
services
we need mental health uh first
responders
we need other types of solutions that
look at black
people with the respect and the dignity
that they deserve
we're of course hearing calls to abolish
or defund the police with many saying
after the verdict that abolition was the
mission
where do you sit with that my hope
is that we continue to ask the tough
questions to be grown-ups
and to do the work of transforming our
society where we can have
a multi-racial democracy that works for
all of us
and so it's step by step and i and i
hope that we will see a world
in which we we don't need police anymore
right where we see
and we are defining safety in a more
broad
and comprehensive way where we're
looking at solutions to challenges in
our community um
in a more dignified manner and i think
we can do that but i do think that's
gonna take
you know that's gonna take commitment
that's gonna take experimentation and
just like we've
invested you know billions of dollars in
one
arena i say like why don't we take those
resources and begin to
experiment with other solutions that
might be out there that we haven't
tested we haven't um given them the
opportunity to try out
in all of these years clearly this isn't
working
clearly we've seen we've seen what is
going on we see the status quo
and you know it's enough it's time to
try something new
can't thank you enough for joining us we
we so appreciate it thank you so so much
thank you
thank you
we'll have more of our conversation with
opal on at quick take on social media if
you want to watch more on scarlett one
thing that she also mentioned earlier
that i found to be so profound was just
this feeling of exhaustion
this verdict coming out she hasn't
stopped working since you know she
hasn't slept
and uh just got the sense from her that
she feels like there's so much left
to continue to do yeah it was a relief
in so many ways just it marked an
a turning point but also as you
mentioned a signal that there's a new
chapter to to forge
on this all right we want to turn our
attention now in the meantime to the
pandemic
and we'll start with india whose numbers
on coven 19 deaths are currently at odds
with the bodies piling up at
crematoriums and burial grounds
so that leaves a data gap that could
keep india unprepared to fight renewed
outbreaks
india reported almost 315 000 new cases
today the world's highest ever daily
tally
by comparison the u.s saw a peak of just
over 314 000 cases
back on december 21st and the new surge
in cobit infections
is threatening to further divide the
global economy between the rich
and the poor and it could damage overall
global growth if the fresh outbreak
spread
or if key sources of demand falter
more people were diagnosed no i can't
get my words out today we're diagnosed
with covid last week than
any other time since the pandemic began
to get a better sense of where in the
world covet is spreading and to track
the global inoculation effort
visit bloomberg.com coronavirus a wealth
of information there
matty coming up after the break the road
to innovation
may help improve your travel time and
climate change
we'll explain when we get back into
[Music]
so
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
replacing gas guzzling cars with greener
vehicles is certainly one way to reduce
our carbon footprint
but the future of transportation is
still very much a work in progress
and one possible step forward is
hyperloop it's a new technology that
promises to be time efficient
and cleaner for the environment it's in
development by a number of companies
including virgin hyperloop whose ceo and
co-founder josh geigel joins us now josh
good to see you on quick take thank you
for joining us
to start us off for those who aren't
familiar with it briefly explain what
hyperloop is we know that elon musk is
very excited about it
or at least he was a couple years ago
but tell us how it works and what kind
of carbon footprint it leaves
we're still very excited about here but
hyperloop's a new form of transportation
it's taking you directly to your
destination without stopping at any
place along the way
and doing that in a i'll say at the
speed of an aircraft
without all the emissions that are
associated with flight
and so we're able to do that by having a
onboard propulsed vehicle
we're able to do that with having
batteries on board and then when you
show up to a station or show up to a
portal
you go when you want to go you're not
waiting you know hours for a train or a
plane to go and
the real i think exciting point of this
for us is this idea of sustainability
without sacrifice
so the point that we can basically go